Dominic King's restaurant would normally
be full of diners enjoying food and
ocean views but not anymore
the village of Capitola was among the
worst to be hit by last week's storm
it stirred up some of the biggest swells
in years waves as high as seven meters
tore up historic piers and damaged homes
and businesses
start Family Restaurant you know we've
had it for like a decade it's it's
definitely places where we've had a lot
of great memories it's more than just a
business
so it's it's really hard to see it kind
of in the state that it's in
utility companies are working to restore
power to tens of thousands of people
California's governor declared a state
of emergency to help with the cleanup
but the damage bill is in the Millions
well they're reasonably Feeling Just
traumatized I mean it's it's emotional
this is our community we know that that
when you look around at the wreckage the
rebuilding looks like in an arduous
process
the storm was powered by two phenomena a
large Airborne stream of moisture called
an atmospheric River and a
hurricane-force system known as a bomb
cyclone
for two days it battered the region with
Fierce winds and torrential rains we
actually witnessed the pier go down and
it was not only a sight to see but to
hear it to hear the pylons wrapping
against each other and the destructive
force of the water was just incredible
and now to come the day after and to see
it looks like a war zone here
it's the third storm like this to hit
California in a week
researchers say climate change is making
them worse and more frequent the severe
weather has killed several people since
New Year's
and as communities try to pick up the
pieces there's no reprieve just yet two
back-to-back storms are barreling in
from the Pacific and more than 15
million Californians remain under flood
watch
Alexandra Byers Al Jazeera